you'll banner first time here in the
Johnson show how you been Joe I'm doing
real well
good to be on with you really appreciate
that so how should fans view this
contract that the Eagles signed Carson
Wentz to Joe well if you're rooting for
the Eagles you should be very very very
happy why is that simple so here's the
simple way to look at it there's 66
million dollars in guaranteed money at
the time of signing in the deal between
this year and next year the Eagles
already owed him 31 million dollars
which was essentially guaranteed not
literally but it says so there's no
scenario because go out and tear his ACL
tomorrow there's no scenario which he's
not making their 31 million dollars so
for an additional 35 million dollars
just think about that in today's NFL for
the additional 35 million dollars they
control his rights for an extra four
years I mean that's half of the
guaranteed money Khalil Matt got and I
personally think this is a perennial pro
ball potential Hall of Fame quality
quarterback if he can stay healthy so
for 35 million dollars even including
the obvious health risk and health
history I don't think he did buy
anything with a downside was less when
the upside was more than four years of
his rights for a 35 million dollar
guarantee that in worst case scenario
you you know you put a dent in your
future budgets and the best case
scenario you have a quarterback for six
years at in today's market very
reasonable prices well in terms of that
Joe his cap number how much if he does
obviously work out to the best-case
scenario for the Eagles that he stays
healthy and he earns his salary every
single year the way that fans see this
number 107 million in guarantees total
or 100 million a huge contract 32
million a year that the idea is that he
eats up too much cap space so the team
can't really build around this
quarterback to get back to the Super
Bowl what do you say to that so there's
two things that they did here very smart
and frankly part of the Eagles tradition
had earned in history for a long time by
doing the deal two years early they put
part of his cap money into the next two
years
so in the going forward basis and the
four new years he has his cap will
actually average significantly less
another thirty two million dollars
because they're eating part of it now so
let's just say that reduced that number
to say it effectively twenty six twenty
seven million dollar average for the for
New Year's if you take 26 or 27 million
dollars over what the cap will be three
years from now you'll see that that's
actually an incredibly marked percentage
and a far better position than almost
anybody in the league will be and who
has a top quality quarterback even the
unsigned guys even if you go to the
maryadas and the Prescotts forget even
you know the Goths and I'm a home so
we're gonna get massive contracts that
twenty six twenty seven million dollars
per year as a percentage of a cap that
by the time it kicks in will be over 200
million dollars in bellowing towards two
hundred fifty million dollars will be
extremely manageable for a team of the
quality quarterback now you know quality
quarterback should be making up for some
deficiencies in some other places so
that's the way they've done it by doing
it two years early by putting part of
the cap charge in the next two years
when they get to the for New Year's I'm
not saying it won't matter
I'm not saying that won't have to be
smart about hitting on some draft picks
and manage the rest of the roster but
they will be in a significantly better
cap position to manage that than any of
the other teams will have a premium
quarterback Joe banner former Eagles
president and Browns front office
executive here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you say Joe to the concept that
this is not good for the league that
teams are forced to put so many eggs
into a one position basket so I guess
still early on in a career
and more often than not now we're seeing
it placed in the basket of a quarterback
that has yet to play or win a single
playoff game what do you say to that Joe
yeah you gotta trust the guys running
these teams and they are evaluating
skills and frankly if they're evaluating
skills aren't good they're not winning
anyway and if they're evaluating skills
are good they're putting in it to the
right people so you know the Aaron
Rodgers and Ben Roethlisberger's you
know we already know what they are I
think we know what when says other than
the injury risk I think we know what
Goff is I think we're going to know what
these guys have been like four or five
years are so if you make the mistake of
taking a guy who's a pretty good
quarterback I don't mean to jump on them
but like what the Ravens did with Flacco
if you take a pretty good quarterback
and pay him like an upper echelon
quarterback your chances of ending the
season at the top of the heap are very
very small and even if you evaluate
properly and and you do it for I think a
wins or if you do it for some of these
other guys that we see that very upper
echelon even though I know no one's won
with a 30-plus Miller quarterback yet
it's just a snapshot in the moment we
won't be saying that too far from now
because it's very doable you do have to
do other things better none of the teams
that have a cheaper quarterback you do
have less flexibility you do have to be
smarter but it's very very doable and
we'll see it happen here reasonably soon
even though if we look at the history of
the last few years it hasn't happened
yet so I think that the teams that are
smart and the teams are evaluating their
own players properly and not being
afraid of making a mistake
in other words letting somebody go that
if you pay in 30 million you can't win
the Super Bowl with him you know take
the chance have the guts to make a
mistake and go back in and find another
quarterback and the teams that have a
guy there's a real difference maker
which I think once is go ahead and pay
whatever it takes and then trust
yourself to build the rest of the roster
and in this case I think unless he
continues to get hurt the Eagles will
look back and go wow that was some of
the best money we ever spent even though
it was a lot of money if you think jack
price what is going wise and dak
Prescott got done yeah Joe what do you
think you know they made a mistake I
mean they and this is normal for the
Cowboys they tend to sign guys later
rather than early and I think we'll get
done before the season but now they have
to
work off of this deal they're going to
end up paying him less than once
probably but not enough once not enough
less than once to make up or what I
think is the qualitative difference that
exists and you know it's a mistake you
know I said this for years when I was at
the Eagles I've said about it in the
media recently if you have a player you
know you want to keep the only waiting
does is increase the price so as they
sit here and wait on the Coopers and
Prescott's
that guys we all know and they all know
by the way so they're agents they're
going to keep the only thing that's
happening is it's becoming more
expensive to keep those guys and they
should have realized that a golfer a
wins could have gotten signed and then
that was only gonna make their deal more
expensive so I get a deal done and it
won't be massively more than it would
have been but the longer they wait the
higher the price is gonna be so when do
you think Goff gets done Joe banner when
do you think that happens well you know
Goff is a little different because you
know they sign late guys also and
they've spent a lot of future money now
if I was running the team I would saying
we need to find a way to get cuffs done
as soon as we possibly can I would have
tried to do it before once got done
because you know the way it gets done is
you don't have to be the best player to
position to be the highest-paid you only
have to be in the group of best players
and have done the most recent deal if
you're in the group of best position you
did the most recent deal you will be the
highest-paid guy at your position so you
know the longer they wait and golf the
more it will cost I would advise them if
anybody asked to do the deal as soon as
they could
the Rams history though is that's not
what they're gonna do they'll probably
make a play at least another year before
they try to do a deal now history isn't
always right but it's usually right and
if they act as they have historically
they're gonna wait another year before
they do the deal and you Joe banner who
knows Andy Reid very well do you think
Andy Reid's gonna go and sign mahomes
sooner than anybody possibly thinks what
do you think well Andy knows all the
things that I believed and I think he
agreed with them when it comes to things
like this and on that basis he will sign
mahomes the first moment he can to the
best deal you get which would be a year
from now he completes his third year
and before somebody does any more deals
that are likely to push the market up
dramatically now if my homes guys are
unreasonable and he doesn't think he's
get any benefit remember the egos just
side wants two years early you you
should get some discount in the deal for
shifting the risk from the player to you
you know for homes guys just want to
drive a homerun and get the biggest deal
they possibly can they may not be able
to get a deal done but I'd be very
surprised if they don't engage in
serious conversations a year from now
and try to do that deal as early as they
possibly can last one for you Joe Banner
do you think we're gonna see the time
where a team elects to not give a huge
contract to a young player with a lot of
promise but zero playoff appearances or
some form of an injury risk and decide
to start from scratch and let that
quarterback go and if so which front
office and quarterback situation do you
think that's most likely to happen so my
regretful answer is that too much of
decision making league is driven by
self-preservation and to ask a head
coach in a general manager to go from
somebody they think is a good
quarterbacks but if you pay him thirty
million dollars a year probably means
you can't win a Super Bowl and risk not
having the replacement in which case you
could win three four or five games next
year and get fired I just don't see
anybody with that mental mindset running
a team right now and taking that risk
and in the only way it happens is if an
owner intervenes and says I understand
the risk I'm part of this
decision-making process I'm going to
support you through this and you know
let's move on because I what I want to
do is win Super Bowls not make the
playoffs and I can't tell you that I can
look at 32 teams and see any that I
think have an owner that would do that
and a general manager head coach that
would trust that and then take that
chance it doesn't mean they shouldn't
but I don't see it happening sorry I
lied I got one last one how do you think
this all affects the CBA conversation
that's beginning right now Joe Banner
well I mean it shouldn't but the history
is that the people tend to see things in
a short term window and be affected by
things that just happen I mean in my
mind the players should be picking two
or three really crucial things and
impact all of the players in a
significant way
and fight and trade off whatever they
need to get that in frankly that's about
the percentage they get it's about
minimum spend requirements it's about
trying to find a way to escalate the
middle class into the pay range that
they deserve it's about those few
primary things if they get distracted by
other things their gains will be too
diffused and they won't get the benefits
that the players as a collective group I
should be getting in these major areas I
meant from the ownership position though
from the membership that some owners are
like why do we have a system where I've
got to pay all this money to somebody
that's barely even 25 years old not
really knowing if they are the long-term
answer I've got a good idea but why do I
need to commit so many cap dollars to
this one player without enough
information the only thing it does from
the owner side is for them to be
motivated to fight harder to keep the
current rookie system so at least they
get the three or four years that they
need remember the union would love to
see a system where all the is only four
years or you can do new contracts after
only two years of a rookie contract
versus three I think it motivates them
to hold on to the current system harder
otherwise all they really care about is
that there's a hard cap manoeuvrable
hard cap and then let each team be as
smart are not smart as they are and
prevail or not but I do think it
motivates them to stay in a fight harder
than they may have otherwise to retain
the rules around the rookie Joe hold you
you the man this is a great chat I knew
I knew I knew I wanted you on my show
it's just taking so damn long I hope
this is the first of many times I'm
happy to do it and glad to be here take
it easy that's Joe banner former Eagles
president former Browns front office
executive CEO for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 under
red TV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app